hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es mal wieder nach langer
zeit einen nachgemacht und zwar hatte
murat sich ein pick-up gewünscht hätte
er ist kein pick up gemacht sondern
einen pink pink war ja ein pick up also
hier das original pick up kicks kapelle
kennt diese pickup kekse wie geht es ihm
an der kasse sind nicht gerade was man
als günstig betrachtet aber ich schweige
ich klasse ja und vier depping ab ich
kann man dazu sagen dass murat hier hier
seinen finger rein gesteckt hat und sich
die ecke auf
aber das hier ist mein papa und er hat
genauso viele zähne wird das original
und hat aber 58 mal mehr kalorien
wahrscheinlich hat er es dreimal so groß
wird es auch regional also eigentlich
muss man drauf legen
ich habe sagen lassen weight watchers
sechs punkte auf dem weg was tabelle
wenn jemand weiß man alles mein herz auf
100 punkte nach den wiesen keks gegessen
hast darfst du wahrscheinlich drei
wochen lang laut weight watchers weight
watchers nichts mehr ist wahrscheinlich
na ja auf jeden fall ist aber super
einfach hergestellt
er besteht aus einem mit der so ein
bisschen am short break
das ist ein ganz knuspriger teig und
ihnen darin eine spielarten und ich
denke wir fangen jetzt einfach mal mit
dem teig an und ich schlafe direkt der
teig ist kein typischer möglich und zwar
habe ich hier ein bisschen anderes
verhältnis und zwar deswegen damit der
teig später nicht ganz nur bewährt
sondern ein bisschen fest hat denn ich
brauche für mein selbstgemachtes pick up
einfach nur sehr knackigen keks ich sage
ich mal da vorne die zutaten
für den keks teig brauche ich 360 gramm
kalte butter eine prise salz 240 gramm
zucker etwas extrakt 61 600 gramm mehl
120 g speisestärke und drei bis sechs
ist afrika das wasser nämlich die kalte
butter die habe ich auch eiskalt aus dem
kühlschrank
selbst jetzt in die küchenmaschine ihr
könnt den teig natürlich auch mit den
händen verkneten oder mit dem
handrührgerät aber er sollte auf jeden
fall sehr kalt so bereitet werden
verarbeitet werden
da kommt jetzt der zucker mit rein prise
salz und etwas von extrakt für den
geschmack und das wird jetzt einfach
kurz verbunden jetzt kommt das geld rein
das ganze habe ich jetzt nur bei
niedriger stufen verrührt denn ich
möchte keine luft einschlagen sondern
möchte einfach nur den teig verbinden
jetzt kommt man noch die trockenen
zutaten mit rein und falls ihr dann
benötigt dann kommt eben noch wasser mit
rein ansonsten lässt uns weg bekommt
einfach immer darauf an wie groß die
eigene bewahren
ich habe jetzt für meinen teil gar kein
wasser benötigt und jetzt werde ich den
teig zu einer großen kugel zusammen
kneten
der teig wird jetzt abgedeckt entweder
können wir das in frischhaltefolie
machen oder um eine frischhaltefolie zu
sparen gibt ihn einfach in eine schüssel
und verdeckten mit einem deckel und dann
muss er jetzt eine halbe stunde in den
kühlschrank damit er noch mal schön kalt
wird und dann gibt's gleich weiter der
teig ist jetzt gut durchgeführt und
jetzt habe ich ihnen einmal noch mal
kurz durchgeknetet damit er einfach
schön geschmeidig ist jetzt nämlich eine
folie zu hilfe und ich werde jetzt das
pink ab also das pick up dreimal so groß
machen wie das original
das original ist acht mal vier groß und
wir machen 24 x 2 france und damit ich
jetzt auch gleich die richtige stärke
also die richtige keks stärke bekomme
nehme ich diese treffer und zwar habe
ich einmal 10 mm und 1 x 3 mm und lege
jetzt übereinander
dann habe ich etwa 310 mm 12 mm hoch
möchte sie haben und dann kann ich das
jetzt mit etwas mehl ausrollen
und jetzt schneide ich die zwei kekse zu
rechnet 12 x 24 cm größer
jetzt habe ich hier die zwei platten und
die muss ich jetzt natürlich auseinander
nehmen damit sie jetzt nicht verschoben
werden werde ich sie jetzt erst mal für
eine halbe stunde einfrieren dann sind
die zweite platte nämlich sehr fest und
ich kann dann damit weiter arbeiten
der teig ist jetzt gut durch gekühlt und
ich habe die tat bleibt ein bisschen
auseinander gesetzt und jetzt habe ich
hier noch mal den original keks und ein
paar ausstechen wir jetzt eben den
schriftzug auch nachmachen und die
kleine löcher werde ich einfach mit
einer modelle werkzeug machen einen
schaschlikspieß würde zum beispiel auch
gehen und diese kleinen zähnchen die
werden dann mit einem messer
angeschnitten
und die buchstaben die werden jetzt nur
ganz leicht eingedrückt
diese kleinen zehen ziehen die könnte
jetzt natürlich so lassen oder ihr macht
zu halbrund mit einem messer oder habe
ziehe einfach eine nadel umgewandelt und
ein bisschen gebogen und kann es damit
die rundungen bisschen aufstecken
die kekse waren jetzt noch mal für etwa
15 bis 20 minuten im gefrierfach und
jetzt werde ich den vorgeheizten
backofen bei 180 grad ober unterhitze
für etwa 30 bis 35 minuten backen
die kekse sind jetzt fertig gebacken und
ich habe sie zum auskühlen hier auf ein
abkühlte den zweiten kicks leg ich auch
gleich drauf aber das noch ein bisschen
warm und zerbrechlich deswegen am besten
so lange liegen lassen bis er eben
abgekühlt ist und ich habe jetzt hier
für die füllung 400 gramm voll mit
kuvertüre und 200 gramm mandeln die habe
ich gerade selber fein gemahlen und die
waren vorher blockiert also ohne haut
die kuvertüre muss jetzt temperiert
werden und zwar deswegen damit sie
später keinen grauschleier bekommt und
schon fest wer deswegen habe ich jetzt
eingeteilt in zwei drittel und dahin
drittel
und jetzt kommen die zwei drittel türe
über ein heißes wasserbad als ich hier
wasser aufkochen lassen und den herd
aber wieder ausgestellt also jetzt das
nicht mehr kochen
jetzt kommt es hier rein in eine zweite
schüssel durch die hitze des wassers
wird jetzt die schokolade auf etwa 50
grad erhitzt und später brauche ich sie
etwa 30 grad haben und deswegen sorgen
dann sorgt man das restliche drittel
dafür dass sie wieder abgeholt
kurator ist geschmolzen jetzt sich sie
vom topf herunter und jetzt kommt das
restliche drittel mit dazu und dadurch
wird die korrekturen 30 grad abgekühlt
die kuvertüre ist temperiert das heißt
die restliche schokolade die hat sich
jetzt auch schon komplett aufgelöst und
im original pick up ist noch haselnuss
mit dabei in der schokolade und ich
werde jetzt aber so machen ich habe
jetzt hier mandeln und gibt die mandel
mit ein
und jetzt muss ich so eine kleine platte
gießen dafür nehme ich jetzt meinen back
rahmen den eckigen und hab da einfach
eine folie darunter damit die schokolade
jetzt nicht ausläuft ist doch ziemlich
flüssig und das hieße ich jetzt hier
rein und las dann im kühlschrank fest
werden
die kubatur ist es geht auch sehr
schnell weise temperiert ist jetzt lese
ich sie einmal vom torten rahmen und ich
hatte die kuvertüre nicht ganz bis zum
rand gestrichen weil ich hier nur die
breite von 12 cm brauchen jetzt kann ich
mir das schön zurecht schneiden
um sich den schokoladen block zwischen
beiden kekse bringen jetzt habe ich hier
den torten retter ein bisschen erwärmt
im backofen und lege jetzt im blog ganz
kurz drauf damit die schokolade ein
bisschen warm wird und schmidt und dann
kann ich sie kekse nämlich
zusammenkleben
jetzt ist der riesen text fertig und ich
habe auch eine verpackung dafür
gebastelt 1 l s pink ob pinkafeld ja
also der keks ist drei mal so groß wie
das original und da gucken wir mal
vielleicht soll ich dazu sagen dass du
im kopf hochgenommen haben bis ein paar
faxen machen
nach oben wieder abgebrochen hatte
machine hat vor sich da es tut mir leid
aber solche abbeißen
nein ich weiß rein ich probiere ich nie
vor der kamera aber kommen den riesen
oder richtig lecker und ich muss sagen
ich bin wirklich schon total berlin
echt mit einem witz dass ich finde den
skating cupcakes richtig cool natürlich
hier schon ein bisschen unhandlich weil
er ebenso große show die bruchgefahr
besteht bei so einem riesen kriegst aber
falls euch auch den spaß mal erlauben
wollte und das rezept nach machen wollt
könnt ihr nachlesen auf settings blog.de
das ist übrigens auch der grund warum
ich nie vor der kamera essen möchte
wenn man danach alles zwischen den zehen
pikante original den pick-up anderen
pickup müssen noch nicht drei mal sehr
schönes 20d also von der länge her und
von der breite her passt er drei mal
drauf 320 fuß
ja also in denen pickup dagegen ja jetzt
oben neu und x 9 x 9 x 33 27 mal so groß
im prinzip ja summa summarum 140 mal so
groß wie der creeks für ein ding gefragt
nach oben 9 in der mit
alles ist rechter de moura dass jetzt
gleich noch mal vor und falls ihr
nachmachen wollen dann geht auf meine
blogs - blog.de ich bin es auch eine
coole idee wenn man da oben was anderes
rein schreibt ja überlegt ich einfach
irgendwas ich wünsche euch jedenfalls
ganz viel spaß beim nachmachen und wir
sehen uns das nächste mal wieder und ihr
könnt mir gerne mal schreiben was ihr
euch als nächstes als nachgemacht
wünscht denn wir hatten uns echt schon
lange nicht mehr
also bis bald fritz baumann riesentopf
mit milch ich muss den eindruck ja